"The Road Not Taken" by Robert Frost.
Two roads diverged in a yellow wood,...
...And sorry I could not travel both and be one traveler,...
...long I stood and looked down one as far as I could...
...To where it bent in the undergrowth;...
Then took the other, as just as fair,...
...And having perhaps the better claim,...
...Because it was grassy and wanted wear;...
...Though as for that the passing there had worn them really about the same,...
...And both that morning equally lay in leaves no step had trodden black.
Oh, I kept the first for another day!
Yet knowing how way leads on to way,...
...I doubted if I should ever come back.
I shall be telling this with a sigh...
...Somewhere ages and ages hence:...
...Two roads diverged in a wood,...
...and I, I took the one less traveled by,...
...And that has made all the difference.